with the 1100 series being so close does
it make sense to buy a 10 series GPU
right now welcome to Haris hobbies so a
lot of people have been waiting several
months to buy a GPU because of the
inflated prices caused by the GPU
cryptocurrency mining demand but once
that died off GPU prices slowly started
their descent back to MSRP and now most
GPUs are at MSRP and some are even being
offered for lower prices than that thus
is it wiser to take advantage of these
great deals or just wait for the 1100
series for the extra performance first
of all make sure that you guys remember
that the price that you guys are seeing
right now aren't limited-time offers so
there is really no rush in trying to get
them before they run out some great
deals may come and go but the 10th
series as a whole is losing value now
because of its age and as a result great
deals will continue to come over the
next couple of weeks and months so don't
feel bad about missing out on a deal
right now because it is very likely that
same deal or even a better deal will
come up very soon plus Nvidia and Adam
board partners have abundant in series
right now in their inventory and their
sales numbers aren't nearly what they
are usually and because of that I can
assure you that they will continue to
offer great deals to get rid of this
excess inventory as soon as possible so
you won't really be missing out by
skipping a deal or waiting a little bit
more and this isn't really as urgent as
it may seem but at the same time have a
threshold don't be unreasonable with the
price that you want and make sure that
your price actually reasonable and
achievable and if the GPU that you were
looking for hits that threshold then
just go ahead and buy that GPU right
then if you are sure that you don't want
the 11 her series cars and that you're
fully satisfied with the 10 series for
example yesterday the GTX 1080 was being
offered for 450 dollars now this is a
great deal but in the past the GTX 1080
has been offered for $500
many times and even right now there are
many offers that are offering the GTX
1084 $500 so $450 isn't really pushing
the normal deals and stuff for the 1080
and because of that it's likely that
this deal will repeat itself so as a
result you may want to skip out on
things like that
however if you found a really good deal
like for example if you found a GTX 1080
for $400 now $400 is almost the MSRP of
the GTX 1070 and $200 less than MSRP of
the GTX 1080
now that's a really good deal and I
doubt that the price would go much lower
than that so at that point I would
recommend that you guys go out and buy
the GTX 280 so before you buy a 10
Series card make sure that the dealer
that you are looking at is rare and
unlikely to be beaten so that's how I
would recommend that you guys buy a 10
series card right now but should you
even buy a 10 Series card in the first
place
first of all the performance of the 1100
series is going to be marginally better
than the 10 series but just because a
new series comes out doesn't make the
old series bad the 10 series are still a
great set of cards and GPUs like the
1060 and 1070 will easily offer your 60
frames per second at 1080p for the next
couple of years you may have to turn
down your settings from altered to high
in a couple of years but those are still
solid cards so in my opinion getting a
10 series or 11 Series card really comes
out to personal preference what do you
value more do you want the best
performance available or the newest
technology or do you just want a good
card at a good price if you're
interested in the new 11 her histories
and wanteds new features like GTD or
sixth memory and a new tearing
architecture I recommend that you just
wait for the 1100 series and get that
because Nvidia is play to detail the 11
order series at the hot chips conference
in August and as a result they will most
likely release all of the main 1100
series cars before the holiday season
because I bet they want to take
advantage of the holiday season so I
doubt they'll miss out on that so it is
just around the corner and not that big
of a weight so I really recommend that
you guys
just wait for that and get that if you
want it because otherwise you'll just
look at your Tim series GPU every single
day and be like man I should have waited
even though the tensor GPU it's probably
a really solid card so if you want the
newest technology and want to be on the
newest platform and you know that you
will not be satisfied if you're not on
that and make sure you just wait and
spend the extra money because it really
does come down to what makes you more
happy and that a couple of dollars isn't
worth being unsatisfied for the next
couple of years however if you don't
care about that fluffy stuff and you
care about the performance that you are
going to get for the money that you're
going to spend then you should consider
getting the Tim Series card but is
that's where the best deals and value
will be at 10 Series prices are bound to
drop even lower especially considering
the 1100 series is so close to launch
and as a result if you really want the
best performance for the best value on
the market right now and the 10 series
is where that is at and you should
consider it getting it and just make
sure that your deal is actually special
before you buy it
overall buying a Lebanon or Series car
that you want will make you much more
satisfied than buying a 10 series card
just because you know that it's a good
deal so if you want the 1100 series then
just spend the extra couple of dollars
right now so you can be satisfied for
the next couple of years however if you
are over that type of praise for the
newest technology and use one a great
reliable card then the 10 series is
still a great option for you but that's
just what I think what do you guys think
are you guys going to be waiting for the
1100 series and do you think the 10
series is still worth it make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read out my comments that
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this view then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one but until next time bye
[Music]